ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi,
I'm Ankur Kotwal,
and I'm an Android
developer advocate.
ALEX DANILO: Hi,
I'm Alex Danilo,
and I'm a Chrome
developer advocate.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Today
we want to talk
to you about some new
developer features
that we've added in the
web view on Android.
So more specifically, Android
4.4-- also known as KitKat--
introduced an updated web
view which is actually
built off the
Chromium web view now.
And that brings a whole range
of new features for developers.
ALEX DANILO: That's
right, Ankur.
In fact, what we've
built now into the web
view is all the
functionality of Chrome.
So what that means to
you as a developer is
that you have all the
HTML5 capabilities that
exist in Chrome shifted
into the web view,
so you can take advantage of
modern HTML5 and all its APIs.
Which is kind of nice.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Absolutely.
So let's have a look at a demo.
ALEX DANILO: Well, before
we should go into the demo,
I just wanted to
point out something.
One thing that's been really
hard for me as a developer
is actually debugging
stuff in a web view.
How do you debug
normally when you're
building Android applications?
ANKUR KOTWAL: I use
Android Studio or Eclipse.
ALEX DANILO: Right,
like I used to as well.
But when I'm developing
on the desktop,
I use Chrome dev tools, which
really makes my life simple.
And now you can actually
do it from the web view.
So why don't we just have
a look at how we actually
go about doing that.
What I have here is we have
a little full screen game.
You hit the start button here.
And what you have is a ball
that you can roll around.
So it's kind of
a standard thing.
But what I'd like
to point out here
is that we're actually using
the motion of the device
to control the ball.
We couldn't do that
before could we, Ankur?
ANKUR KOTWAL: No.
So this is now
the accelerometer.
And the Chromium
web view is mapping
that hardware accelerometer
on your Android device
straight through to
the web view itself.
So this is a demo
that Alex, you built.
And we now this app here is
effectively-- it's a web app.
It's just a thin wrapper of an
app that drops in a web view.
And it's just a login
to your site, isn't it?
ALEX DANILO: Exactly.
And so the beauty of this is
that now we have this web view.
And in the old days,
prior to Kit Kat,
you'd be thinking,
how I debug this?
It's really hard.
But what I can do is then
come over here to Chrome,
and I can just go over and
have a look at Chrome inspect.
If I go and have a
look at that, you'll
suddenly see the devices that
are connected to my laptop
visible.
And here we actually
see we've got a Nexus
10 running this
application at the moment.
And you can see the
actual web view itself.
So for Android
developers, you'd be
familiar with this
com.alex.roller.
So that's the namespace my
app's been developed in.
So all I have to do is
click this Inspect link,
and lo and behold, we have
the full Chrome dev tools
experience.
Identical to what
happens on a desktop.
But now it's actually
talking into the device,
and I can look at the DOM.
I can write point JavaScript.
I can modify the DOM on the fly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And this is not
a special build of your app,
right?
ALEX DANILO: No.
ANKUR KOTWAL: It works for
debug and release builds.
ALEX DANILO: Exactly.
That's the beauty of it.
This is for any app that
uses the Chrome web view now,
which is fantastic.
So I can drill down,
look in the DOM here.
And of course, I can
see the Start button,
but there's no game content.
You can see hovering
over it, it's
actually changing what
you can see on the screen.
So if I actually tap
the start to start
the game you see all of a
sudden all these new elements
appear in the DOM.
So this is a live DOM.
Actually on the fly.
And if you have a
look at down here
at the very bottom, which
I have that highlighted.
You see the rotation
and the transforms
are changing on the fly.
So as the ball is moving around,
this is actually changing live.
So this is just fantastic.
Although the holes that
the ball falls into,
they're a bit dark for me.
What do you think?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, I mean
all of our UX research
shows that you should
use lighter colors, Alex.
ALEX DANILO: I
think you're right.
So why don't we do that.
Why don't we actually change
the color that we're seeing.
So if I go back up the top--
since I actually wrote this I
know what to look at, but--
ANKUR KOTWAL: I
notice that says SVG.
That's also a new feature of
the Chromium web view, right?
We now have SVG support.
ALEX DANILO: That's right.
We brought in SVG support.
I think it was Honeycomb
was the first version that
supported it.
But now the web view
actually has it.
And it flies.
So I've got these gradients here
that are used for the holes.
So if you have a look,
here's this gradient
that's black and gray.
I might just decide that I'd
prefer the holes to be blue.
Start as blue.
So if you actually
watch as I change that,
all the holes suddenly
changed to blue.
So we're actually
modifying the live DOM.
And this is an
incredible feature.
So the ball itself, let's
go down to the ball.
Let me have a look.
You'll notice we have a
Chrome logo there on the ball.
See, that's a
Chrome logo spinning
around which is controlled
by this image here.
Now I could actually just
select it and delete it.
And lo and behold, our
ball has become a blue ball
because I've taken
away that image.
And this is really bad
because now we can't the ball
from the holes.
So we can actually
change the color
of that circle that the
ball, and it becomes red,
and we can again see
what it looks like.
So they have it.
We have actual live editing,
on the fly of our web app,
without any code changes.
And you can do this from your
desktop, from your laptop,
on the fly.
It's just an awesome
new feature in KitKat.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And
we should also add
that when we
connected with Chrome
we didn't need ADB or the
developer tools installed.
It's all built into Chrome now.
And you can connect
directly, it just shows up.
ALEX DANILO: That's
exactly right.
Pro tip, for all the
developers our there,
turn on hardware
acceleration because that
will make your apps
fly with the new view.
So hardware acceleration,
HTML5 features, I love KitKat.
It's fantastic.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Thank you.